[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a tradition unlike any other
it feels like every year at this time
after the voting for the baseball hall
of fame we have bob costas on to
somehow come up with answers for major
league baseball and the uh
baseball writers of america bob good
morning how are you
hello dan how you doing uh
it feels like this is a tradition where
i go let's get bob on and he can explain
what happened or what didn't happen
um you're a voice of reason here what
happened yesterday
well what happened is that curt
schilling appears to have talked and
tweeted his way
out of the hall of fame no matter how
out of bounds a lot of his proclamations
have been and understand joel sherman
of the new york post one of the best
baseball reporters said this yesterday
on the mlb
and network remember he got more than 70
percent
of the vote and a very very large
percentage of the players past and
present
in the baseball hall of fame are
relatively conservative politically
this isn't a matter of republican
democrat conservative liberal
and i say this as somebody who through
the years has had a good relationship
with curt schilling going all the way
back to when he was with the phillies
but a lot of what he has said
and tweeted over the last few years is
just completely out of bounds
including supporting the insurrection of
the capital and
things he said about writers as a group
not specific individuals
so without that he'd be over the line
now we might have expected clemens and
bonds
who made a bit of a move up to 60
percent or so
a year ago to inch at least a little bit
closer and they barely moved
at all part of the reason could be and
i'm just guessing here dan
it's this assuming they're able to have
a ceremony
fingers crossed this july in cooperstown
some voters may have said look
these three these specific three call
them the rogues gallery of the hall of
fame
schilling clemens bonds they could be a
class of their own
next year but why should there be any
discordant notes
surrounding derek jeter especially
universally popular
bus ted simmons and larry walker and
whoever represents
marvin miller next year the two
by statistics certain hall of famers who
come on the ballot for the first time
are a-rod and big poppy now i think
david ortiz will get a higher percentage
of the vote
but whatever whiff of steroids is
attached
to big poppy who's very popular and was
a great great hitter
that may keep him out as a first ballot
guy and it's going to take
a rod a while if ever and the scott
rowlands of the world who are up around
50 percent
todd helton's who've made a move
sheffield moved up
none of those people loom for next year
omar vasquel was on his way up until the
allegations of domestic abuse
halted him but he was only in his third
or fourth year so this time for him to
be rehabilitated so to speak
so as you look at it it's possible that
if someone's going to vote
for shilling bonds or clemens someone
has been a holdout
perhaps their initial reasons were just
let them twist in the wind
my semi-protest will be says this voter
this imaginary voter
my semi-protest will be that i make them
wait until the last minute
i'll vote for them in year 10. well it
turns out that year 10
sets up that it could very well be those
three people on the stage clemens bonds
schilling if enough voters come around
to say okay the coast is clear
in this situation i can see it it
doesn't rain on anybody else's parade
i can see it next year i'm not saying
that will happen but
i wouldn't be at all surprised if the
three of them move up
closer to 75 percent if not over it in
there
how do you think the baseball writers
would have reacted or would react if
schilling was already in the hall of
fame
and he had these tweets he had these
comments he had this stance
well there'd be all kinds of articles
written about it condemning it
but i doubt uh that he'd be removed the
baseball writers might be able to make a
statement
but it would be up to the board of
directors of the hall of fame to remove
him or anybody else
and then you'd have to begin thinking
about boy
if we pull on that thread does the
entire garment unwind
these aren't the only sorts of offenses
that people might find
objectionable are we going to go back
over the personal history to the extent
that we know it
of everybody who's in the hall of fame
and by the way
although it's apples and oranges a
little bit o.j simpson's bust is still
in canton
yeah i just wonder like schilling has no
crimes against baseball
and that's right that's true so just
trying to sort this out
bonds has crimes against baseball a-rod
does pete rose does
like i'm just trying to sort this out
and wonder what goes
into the process here bob because i may
not like what kurt tweets
but i could look at him as a baseball
hall of famer
um i didn't question his character uh
charitable contributions when he played
when he played and i don't know if it's
just
i i should can i separate and not just
look at that
is that or am i being totally naive here
no i don't think you're being naive i've
said this for years now he kind of
stepped up some of his tweets in the
past year
to his detriment when it comes to the
hall of fame but he was out there
for the last few years and i always said
that if i was a voter and as you know
it's only baseball writers who have a
vote
i always would have voted for kurt
chilling i would have voted for him
on the first ballot the best strikeout
to walk ratio of any pitcher
since 1900 remarkable postseason record
in addition to 11 and 2
he pitched in five elimination games in
october
his record was 4-0 and the other one in
which he had a no decision his team also
won the game
and his era in those five games was 1.37
plus it's a hall of fame it's not just
statistics he's part of baseball lore
the bloody sock game the red sox yankee
rivalry all that stuff
uh so i think he's a hall of famer and i
i would like to see him elected but
someone's gonna have to put an arm
around his shoulder if he is elected and
say look
kurt this acceptance speech has to be
100
about baseball and baseball only we
don't care if you talk about the bloody
sock for 15 minutes
but we don't want you talking about
donald trump for 15 seconds
uh the bonds and clemens
dilemma that comes up every year here um
do you think that their fate will be
better uh resting in the hands of the
veterans committee
not necessarily um you know depends upon
the composition of
the particular committee it's not all
the same they break it up into
eras and depending upon the composition
of a 16 person
panel some of those people may feel
particularly negatively
toward it you know joe morgan for
example the late great joe morgan who
was on the
boards uh directors of the hall of fame
board of directors uh he was always
adamant about no steroid guys in the
hall of fame i don't know that that's
universal
but there's certainly a strain of
thinking in that way so i don't think
the veterans committee
necessarily gives bonds and clemens
a better shot at it yeah i'm just trying
to
and i don't know if schilling will be
better suited for the veterans committee
like
i think he thinks so um would you say
schilling has a better chance with the
veterans committee than bonds and
clements do
i think so um it's schilling's feeling
that he was
respected by those he played with and
against
um and that's certainly true with with
very very few
exceptions you know he specifically
specifically took out after writers
i may not have the exact phrasing
correct but
there was a cartoon that he put out on
facebook a couple years ago whatever it
was
and it was journalist rope
tree some assembly required
even if he says that was tongue-in-cheek
come on so i think some people may have
taken that personally which would be
understandable
a-rod testing positive twice so there's
no rumor
innuendo here like he's had a great five
years since he retired by the way
like it's it's like a body switch with
him and jeter that
all of a sudden a-rod's doing shark tank
and sunday night baseball he's at the
inauguration
does any of this matter when it comes to
voting next year or
these writers gonna go yeah it's nice
but you know let's go back and look at
all the things that he did
in uh how he harmed baseball well a
couple of things
there dan there are some writers who
make a distinction and it's a valid one
between players who may have used before
baseball codified testing and specific
penalties
and those who went ahead and did it even
after
that all had been codified and a-rod is
certainly
in that category then on top of that he
sued baseball and he had to sit out
a year so he's got all those demerits
but at the same time look what's
happened
a few years ago at the world series i
was in the production trailer with a
bunch of knowledgeable baseball guys
and i just happened to say you know a
few years from now
a-rod's q rating is going to be higher
than derek jeter's
and they looked at me as if i had three
heads but it turns out now to be correct
not because jeter's
is negative necessarily or has any more
negatives next to it
but because a-rod in public perception
you know
being about to marry j-lo i don't know
if they got married or not yet but
they're engaged whatever being with
j.lo and being on tv and he's a handsome
guy
when he walks out on jimmy fallon or
whatever the place goes nuts
so in terms of public perception
he's been largely rehabilitated the
writers are a little bit more aware than
that
but many of them may say to themselves
wait a second where are the guidelines
here
ken rosenthal very respected writer for
the athletic
has been saying that recently i don't
know how to parse
all these things pete rose on the
outside looking in
a rod not only a celebrity but he's a
baseball figure
he's on espn you know where what's
what's the uh what's the objective
standard here what's the consistent
standard here
and what are the voters supposed to make
of it maybe maybe the fact that a-rod
uh has been brought back into baseball
not just that his public
uh persona is better than it once was
but that he's part of baseball maybe he
doesn't work for the commissioner's
office but
uh baseball accepts him as as a fixture
on
sunday night baseball and at other
baseball events
maybe maybe that makes it easier for
some people to say look
i give up i'm just doing it on what the
numbers tell me
and you also have this argument which i
don't buy into but you'll hear
hey this guy was a hall of famer before
he started using
um it doesn't work that way your career
is your career if you use
then you're not a hall of famer in my
opinion it's
not like man that guy was father of the
year uh well until he had his mistress
but he was father of the year for
like it doesn't work that way well but
for a lot of people it does
it's obvious that a lot of the voters
make a distinction
between let's say bonds and clemens who
clearly would have been first ballot
hall of famers inner circle hall of
famers
if they had retired in the late 1990s
which is generally when
we think especially with bonds is pretty
good evidence that that's uh where it
began
otherwise sami sosa would be up around
60
instead of at 17 percent he hit over 600
homers he it's
better than 60 homers three times and
he's part of baseball history in the
in the late 90s and early 2000s so a
huge percentage of the electorate does
make the very distinction that you're
saying doesn't matter
yeah i know i know i'm in the minority
here but you know it just comes down to
it's a museum
it's for the fans and you know
if the fans want people and they want to
see it in their museum then great i
like i i got to the point where i don't
enjoy baseball
because it feels like there's there's
always things
on the periphery and never the game we
don't we don't celebrate the game
and that that's the really disheartening
thing with all of this we're not even
celebrating the hall of fame or
possibility of guys moving up it's all
about the guys who don't get in
and that's unfortunate really is yeah
well after after next year
that kind of moves into the shadows once
again no pun intended wasn't the book
called game of shadows
and i didn't mean it that way
after the final year of eligibility that
takes care of it but you want to talk
about celebrating the game
let's say for the sake of argument it's
possible if not likely
that all three of those guys get in and
that's the trio
on the stage no one else is elected you
know
simmons and walker and jeter have had
their their day this summer
and those are the three sure why not
yeah you know it's a good story man
isn't it why not
you know cheer me up and tell me a great
hank aaron story before i say goodbye
well you may know this one already but i
just find it
especially inspiring um
he loved his dad he wasn't complaining
about his dad it was just the reality
of the day when he told his father when
he was a little kid
i want to grow up to be a pilot his dad
said
ain't no colored pilots and colored was
the the term used not only by many white
americans but most black americans then
ain't no colored pilots when he later
said i want to play in the major leagues
he said ain't no colored ball players
in the late 1940s when hank was 14 15
years old
the dodgers come barnstorming up from
florida after spring training as teams
used to do on their way back to brooklyn
and they stopped in mobile to play an
exhibition game and jackie robinson
addressed a small group of black
citizens at a storefront it was either a
drugstore or a grocery store
on the morning of the game and young
hank aaron
skipped school to go to see him speak he
already had an idea that this was
a guy who would inspire him this was
someone he looked up to
and then later when the game was played
that afternoon
hank didn't have the money for a ticket
in fact when he left home
uh to first play professional baseball
he had two dollars
in his pocket that's that's how
impoverished the family was so he didn't
have money for a ticket
and he climbed a tree out beyond the
right field fence of the ballpark in
mobile and from there
he got his first glimpse of jackie
robinson as a ballplayer
and from there you think about it he
goes on to become
in many ways because of his greatness as
a player and because of his social
significance
he is the most significant baseball
player
since jackie robinson his idol and
inspiration
in effect figuratively he took the baton
from him
and he carried it with great dignity and
honor it's 42 after the hour which seems
only appropriate with jackie robinson
so there you go and in two minutes it'll
be 44. you cheered me up bob
there you go you did it i'll talk to you
next year at this time
all right be well have a good 2021 thank
you bob
costas this saturday mlb network will
re-air
the um sounds of baseball episodes with
vin scully on michaels
and tony kubeck it starts at two eastern
hosted by bob
and tom verducci